let's talk a little bit about what's
going on between these two teams of
49ers and the Chiefs and Chris something
came up yesterday that you and I have
discussed from time to time yeah because
it was back in 2017 when people were
deciding what they were doing at the top
of the draft there were some teams that
had some picks in the top five and one
of the teams wanted a quarterback and
that team traded up a spot I can't
remember what team it was but that team
traded up to get Mitch trubisky and the
other team
wasn't interested in one of the other
great quarterbacks who's in this game
Patrick Mahomes the 49ers when they
dropped from two to number three they
went with the defensive lineman and your
guy Kyle Shanahan wasn't interested in
bringing in Patrick Mahomes yeah he
addressed yesterday I'm gonna hear from
Kyle Shannon he addressed how much he
looked into the possibility of drafting
Patrick Mahomes with that third pick in
the 2017 draft here's Shanahan from
Tuesday
I didn't look into them obviously as
much as I should have
um I think it was I mean we definitely
looked into him studied all his tape
um was just a freak that could make any
throw
um had the ability to do anything I
thought it was a little bit different
situation for us we had the second pick
in the draft did not feel like from all
the Intel you getting stuff that he was
going to go that high and it was a
little different situation for us just
because I think it's pretty well
documented of just the relationship I
had with Kirk and being in Washington
and everything and I felt very confident
that he wasn't going to stay there so
anytime you go into a season knowing
that a franchise quarterback's gonna be
available the next year it made me a lot
more picky with what we were looking at
Kyle Shannon referring to Kirk Cousins
who was entering his last year with
Washington became the free agent of
course along the way they traded for
Jimmy Garoppolo but you know he he said
something that caught my eye yeah their
intelligence suggested to them that
Patrick Holmes wasn't going to be taken
High further proof that guys like Andy
Reid Sean Payton Mike McCarthy kept
their mouths shut and nobody else knew
how much they regarded right Patrick
because if they had caught and went to
that if she if if Shanahan had heard
that Andy Reid loves this guy or Sean
Payton had him as the number one player
in the board look at him a little more
carefully and maybe have an epiphany
that this is the guy we have to have I
will say this uh and I'm patting myself
on the I tried to give him that Epiphany
to a degree I did I know I've talked to
you about this because you know Shanahan
yeah he liked Mahomes he definitely did
I remember we had a we had a
conversation like two weeks before the
draft he was asking me about a few guys
in the draft and he said yeah man I just
I don't know if I want to really take a
defensive lineman with a number two pick
and do that and I said to him I said
have you did you look at my homes you
know because I was in love with my homes
I was you know just blabbering about
them all the time oh man yeah you think
he's that good the second pick and you
know ultimately what happened is he had
his his sights set on Kirk Cousins he
knew it was a guy that was going to be
available and I really think he thought
I'm gonna get him when this first
season's over he knows my system and
then in year two of my uh my career here
in San Francisco we can kind of just hit
the ground running and I think he just
was planning on that happening all along
but of course things changed all right
so a couple things here one I want
credit for what Kyle Shanahan just said
because Mike on this very show last week
did I not say we need to start talking
about all the teams that passed on yeah
a lot of people get a free pass not just
who cares I said what happened with the
Niners because Patrick Holmes is such a
great talent right that you can put
aside need if you had a quarterback it
doesn't matter Patrick Holmes was better
right some of those teams at the top of
the draft had quarterbacks but guess
what Patrick Mahomes is better the other
thing that's interesting from this and
that was the first time I saw it
the Bears and I don't want to make this
about the bears but it's so clear that
if the Bears had moved on from John Fox
maybe when they should have after two
years instead of having that lame duck
coach come back for a third year they
might have had a different mind in the
building who said hey let's look at
someone else because if you remember
Ryan Pace didn't tell John Fox that
they're projected he had no idea right
and you see this clip where Kyle
Shanahan didn't know about you know Sean
Payton and Andy Reed and all these other
teams so high on Patrick Mahomes so it
was clear if you maybe got a different
mind in the building they would have
also been high on Patrick Mahomes
history is different now I'm upset there
was a small small group of coaches Who
Loved Patrick Mahomes and they kept
their mouths shut if you bring Matt Nagy
in a year earlier which he might not
have been ready for the job but he was
he obviously knew about Patrick Holmes
that's that story that was in the
Chicago Tribune a couple months ago
where it was clear that the Chiefs had
been targeting Patrick Holmes for a year
plus and they were enamorous with him
that building new the other buildings
just didn't figure it out and it just
shows it's it's fascinating to look at
how these games can be won in you know
the middle of uh you know October not on
the field but a guy scouting Department
right or maybe it's February when
they're going through the draft all
these things matter and that's why we're
here and credit to Andy Reid the master
stroke was recognizing that Sean Payton
the Saints coach felt the same way about
Mahomes that Reed did because Reed moved
all the way up to number 10 cut the line
one spot in front of the Saints to get
my homes when the saints were ready to
draft Mahomes Drew Brees was in the
draft room and they had to go tell Drew
hey we might we may be taking a
quarterback here you just got to be
ready for it he's there with guests yeah
and it's like this could be a an ugly
scene yeah when we read off this name
and it's quarterback right but that's
how close it was for the Saints to take
remember remember Mike Mike Glennon went
down to like The Fan Fest at Soldier
Field then they picked Mr risky so it's
happening in organizations where you
know it can happen like that and a guy
can be moved on from you know in a blink
of an eye one thing we got to say too I
mean hey Andy Reid we know he's the
magic man with quarterbacks he's got an
incredible eye but really the the
architect of it is Brett Veach the GM in
Kansas City he was the guy that thrusted
Mahomes onto Reed's radar you know and I
don't know I know I've talked to Brett
Veach about it we have together I've
read articles about it but I know he
gave him reports and hey this guy is one
of the best quarterbacks I've ever seen
or evaluated uh and I know Andy you know
at first we're probably a little
skeptical about a comment like that but
I think when he turned on the film you
know it was for me it was easy to see I
think a lot of people got fooled by the
the T on the helmet and that it was
Texas the conference the conference as
well conference whatever he's played as
you really know how to play the position
or the stats real all of those things I
think and of course nobody's ever really
come out of Texas Tech and been
successful so I think all those things
hurt my homes and people's eyes who
couldn't just take it for what it was
worth that that guy was awesome forget
the conference and everything else it's
just about that guy and that's where
he's special I think there's another
untold story as it relates to how the
Chiefs discovered Patrick Mahomes
because Brett feetch wasn't the GM at
the time right John Dorsey was yeah and
John Dorsey got fired not long after
Mahomes was drafted and I'd love to know
if that's what Dorsey was saying yeah
about Mahomes because if he wasn't all
in on Mahomes and vich was and Veach
sold Andy Reed on it that becomes a huge
data point in deciding who the GM should
be going forward definitely because
Veach got it right clearly and if Dorsey
wasn't on board with avici was saying
Dorsey got it wrong yeah all this stuff
is fascinating by the way nice Ricochet
shot at uh Wes Welker there saying no
one has ever come out of Texas Tech but
I met a quarterback position no but it's
true I you know I know myself like I'm
not an expert I don't watch the film
like you I'm not a Insider like Mike
Florio I saw Big 12 and I was like yeah
you're like yeah I know they're down a
million every game they don't play
defense every every single game is video
game scores of course he's gonna throw
for seven touchdowns right against you
know Baylor and all this stuff and and
that is how we were all wired now you
see obviously Baker Mayfield and Kyler
Murray and the big 12. you start to
realize the Reps actually are good well
you get to do that a little bit too as
long as the guy has talent and it's not
fake Talent you're just looking at the
stat line at the end and the way the
game has changed how the pro game now
mirrors the college game a lot more than
it did 15 years ago where 15 years ago
if you got a guy like this who's playing
in this offense and then he goes and
plays the NFL and everyone says well we
want him under Center and we want them
to you know play a different style and
there's no uh different rpos everything
that's going on now in the Pro game is a
lot closer to the college game so the
transition I mean remember that like you
know guys would come out of the Big 12
like they could never make it I I would
to speak to your point I mean I was at
the senior mall I was oh my God we were
a real conference then we played defense
but
I mean you know we were back in those
days I mean you think Oklahoma and Bob
Stoops and Colorado and Nebraska yeah
yeah right right yeah
but but um yeah but you're right I mean
Cliff Kingsbury in our Senior Bowl had a
really hard time taking Center snaps I
mean it was like it was a great thing to
him right he's like what and you know he
had issues with it of course got it got
the got a hold of it but I I do think
there was that stigma to Big it was
always the pro style offense you saw
teams you're like well that's not a pro
style offense we can't draft that guy
and now it's completely different and
you look at guys in all different
conferences all different offenses and
you're like you know what we can change
our office exactly let's actually fit
him right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports